in June of 2017 I volunteered with a
group at a local food pantry on the
south side of my home city in Atlanta
Georgia it was a Friday afternoon the
day of their weekly food giveaway and as
I drove up I saw people beginning to
arrive many with their rolling carts in
tow prepared to receive their food
supply for the week as I was walking in
the door there are about 40 people
outside waiting in line and I was so
excited because there are very few
things I enjoy more than giving back but
then as I entered the room where the
volunteer meeting was taking place I
immediately realized we weren't about to
give these people any real meals we were
essentially just giving them food I took
my place on the assembly line forget
this I was in charge of making sure that
the Weight Watchers ding-dongs made it
into every family's back as the bag
started to come around I'm thinking to
myself what on earth are we doing here
each bag contains two 20 ounce diet
snapples a gallon of barbecue sauce a
bag of kettle potato chips a box the
superhero shaped vegetable enriched
macaroni noodles a box of Velveeta
breakfast bars a can of refried beans a
can of sweet peas a miniature can of
corn I can't forget about those
ding-dongs and french fried green onions
you know the kind that go on top of a
green bean casserole and that was it we
made over a hundred of those bags that
day and people indeed stood in line to
receive one but a feeling came over me I
felt bad and a little angry it was like
how could I even feel good about the
work that I was doing when I knew for a
fact they're not one mill is to come for
the food we had just given to over 100
families I mean who wants to have a meal
with barbecue sauce and ding-dongs and
the reality is I've been part of this
process all my life I've participated in
food drives I've collected cans since I
was a kid I've donated in the grocery
store
times than I can count I've volunteered
at shelters I've worked in food pantries
and I'm sure like me so many of you have
too
in 2013 I even created a pop-up
restaurant called Sunday soul and I read
it tables and chairs and linens and I
printed out menus and I took these
experiences to alleyways underneath
bridges and in parks to allow people
that were experiencing homelessness to
dine with dignity so I've been vested in
this fight for quite some time and
almost every major US city the food bank
is viewed as a beloved community
institution corporations and volunteers
down on a weekly basis to sort through
food items and make boxes of food for
the needy and canned drives they warm
the hearts of schools and office
buildings that participate and fill the
shelfs of food banks and food pantries
across the nation this is how we work to
end hunger you know what I've come to
realize is that we are doing hunger
wrong we are doing the same things over
and over and over again and expecting a
different end result we've created a
cycle that keeps people dependent on
food banks and pantries on a monthly
basis for food that is often not well
balanced and certainly doesn't provide
them with a healthy milk in the u.s. our
approach to doing good or what we call
charity has actually hindered us from
making real progress we're educating the
world on how many people are food
insecure there are television
commercials billboards massive donations
the engagement of some of our biggest
celebrities in the fight but the
ever-present reality is that even with
all of this work millions of people are
still going hungry and we can do better
globally eight hundred and twenty-one
million people are hungry that's one in
nine people on this planet and here in
the United States nearly 40 million
people experience hunger every single
year including more than 11 million
children they go to bed hungry every
night yet we're wasting more food than
ever before more than 80 billion pounds
a year to be exact the EPA estimates
that food waste has more than doubled
between 1970 and 2017 in an hour counts
for 27
of everything in our landfills and as
this food sits it gradually rots and
producers harmful methane gas a leading
contributor to global climate change
you have the waste of the food itself
the waste of all the money associated
with producing this now wasted food and
the waste of Labor with all of the above
and then there's the social inequity
between people who really need food and
can't get it and people who have too
much and simply throw it away all of
this made me realize that hunger was not
an issue of scarcity but rather a matter
of logistics so in 2017 I set out to end
hunger using technology
after all food delivery apps have begun
to explode on the scene and I thought
surely we can reverse engineer this
technology and get food from businesses
like restaurants and grocery stores and
into the hands of people in need I
believe that technology and innovation
have the power to solve real problems
especially hunger so in 2017 I created
an app that would inventory everything
it is that a business sells and make it
super easy for them to donate this
excess food that would typically go to
waste at the end of the night all the
user has to do now is click on an item
tell us how many they have to donate and
our platform calculates the weight in
the tax value of those items at time of
donation we then connect with local
drivers in the shared economy to get
this food picked up and delivered
directly to the doors and nonprofit
organizations and people in need I
provided the data and the analytics to
help businesses reduce food waste at the
source by letting them know that the
item the items that they waste
repeatedly on a regular basis and they
either saved millions of dollars
our mission was simple feed more waste
less and by 2018 our clients included
the world's busiest airport Atlanta's
hartsfield-jackson and we were working
with brands and corporations like Hormel
chick-fil-a and Papa John's we even had
the opportunity to work with the NFL for
Super Bowl 53 and over the last two
years we've worked with over 200
businesses to divert more than 2 million
pounds of edible food from landfills
into the hands of people that needed it
most
[Applause]
[Music]
this is accounted for about 1.7 million
meals and allowed us to start to expand
our efforts to other cities like
Washington DC Chicago Miami Philadelphia
more that's just one approach that
actually tackles the problem another was
the launch of our pop-up grocery stores
we recover excess food from businesses
and set up free community grocery stores
right in the middle of food deserts we
bring out a chef and we do on-site taste
testings and allow families to leave
with recipe cards we give every family
reusable grocery bags and allow them to
simply shop - the price tag we wanted to
give people access to meals and not just
food we wanted to change the way that we
think and work to solve hunger in this
country get people to believe that we
can solve hunger not as a nonprofit not
as a food bank but as a social
enterprise with the goal of reducing
waste and ending hunger but it hasn't
been as easy as I thought to change the
narrative and the thought process on how
we think that hunger can be solved in
2016 France became the first country to
ban supermarkets from throwing away
unused food instead they must donate it
and they're fine if they don't Italy
followed suit becoming a second European
nation to pass an anti food waste ban
and they stated it so simply as it was
passed through legislation we have
millions of pounds of good food going to
waste and we have poor people that are
going hungry that's simple
Denmark now has a mandated food waste
grocery store its name we food they
recover excess food from local grocery
stores and sell it at up to a 50% off
discount they then use all the proceeds
and donate it to emergency aid programs
and social need issues for the people in
need it's name it has been held as the
goodwill of grocery and last year the
world got its first pay which you can
grocery store when feed it forward open
in Toronto their stocks their shelves
remain stocked by recovering excess food
from major supermarkets and allowing
families to simply pay what they can at
the grocery store this is amazing
this innovation
we need more of everyone can take on
that the roles of changing the attitudes
about how we solve hunger when we think
of how we've allowed innovation and
technology to change our lives from how
we communicate with each other to how we
view our entertainment to how we even
receive food it's amazing that we
haven't solved hunger yet
we literally have cars that can drive
themselves in millions of people that
cannot feed themselves with millions of
dollars being donated to in food
insecurity we should have solved hunger
years ago and I asked myself I asked
myself why can't we escape this vicious
cycle
why only solve this problem I remember
meeting with investors and pitching the
idea trying to raise funds for my
business and one of them said to me in
true seriousness hunger is already being
solved as if millions of people weren't
going to go to bed hungry that very
night and if there was nothing else to
do and the reality is one would think
that hunger is being solved but the
truth is is being worked on if we really
want to solve hunger then we have to
change the way we've been doing it the
same actions will always garner the same
results there are hundreds of social
entrepreneurs all over the world they
have a focus to solve really big
problems like hunger but they'll never
get the same support that we give
national hunger fighting organizations
and food banks but if given the
opportunity they have the ability to
foster insight and perhaps before
thinking enough to solve this problem
that's why I'm traveling the world and
I'm really talking about what hunger
looks like in America and explaining the
difference between giving people access
to food and access to mills I've been
meeting with City Council members and
city organizers across the US and
telling them that technology indeed does
have the power to connect businesses
with surplus food to people in need and
explaining to them what a meal can
actually mean to a family I've been
meeting with school boards and school
districts to talk about how we feed
hungry children in healthcare
organizations sharing the message that
food is health and food is life and that
by solving hunger we can solve so many
more problems so if you want to know
though we don't live in a nation we're
perfectly good food goes to waste when
our neighbors don't have food
to eat that we need to change the laws
we need to introduce new policies and
most importantly we need to change our
minds and our actions food drives are
fine food banks serve a huge purpose and
yes sometimes I like ding dongs too but
the reality is that food drives do not
solve hunger and if we are smart about
connecting the dots that are right in
front of our noses we can do far more
than give a family a box of superhero
shaped vegetable enriched macaroni
noodles and a gallon of barbecue sauce
to feed themselves instead we can give
them back their dignity
perhaps we can increase school
attendance in schools we can improve the
health outcomes for millions and most
importantly we can reduce food waste in
our landfills creating a better
environment for all of us the thing I
love most is that we can feel good about
it in the process if we solve hunger we
have nothing to lose and everything to
gain so let's do it
thank you
[Applause]